when is 30 million dollars not enough
money when your reality show diva keep
watching to find out which of your
favorite reality show divas got the boot
for demanding way too much reality shows
are a mixed bag when it comes to content
quality consistency longevity and even
their supposed reality
since their only theoretical bond is a
lack of word-for-word scripting the
reality genre is actually dozens of
genres some follow legitimate
professionals as they showcase their
unusual or exciting trade and others
just gather interesting personalities in
one place in order to watch the
unavoidable explosion but if there's one
thing that truly unites almost every
reality program to ever air it's their
one overarching purpose to be glaringly
obvious cash grabs over the years
hundreds of celebrities and characters
either on their way to the top or
tumbling back down from it have used
reality shows to keep the money coming
in it can be a smart strategy and
profitable investment especially for
talent unable to perform like they used
to like in the case of hulk hogan or
those with no real talent at all but as
with any financial endeavor some people
get greedy while some reality stars have
bagged huge payoffs per episode some
kept the negotiations open a little too
long and paid the price here are a
couple of reality tv cast members who
were too greedy and were fired for it
what's wrong with you guys
my diamond earring came up in the ocean
and it's
gone there's people that are dying it's
likely that keeping up with the
kardashians is the most iconic reality
show of all time it ran for a staggering
20 seasons totaling 280 episodes and six
specials and maintained impressive
viewership numbers throughout the show
took an already high profile family and
turned them all into a-listers some of
whom launched their own empires it's
hard to underestimate the effect that
the show had not just on the family but
on reality television in general that's
why it's equally hard to understand how
a show that huge could possibly end
until you follow the money by season 20
family matriarch kris jenner had become
unsatisfied with the 30 million dollars
her family earned per season she lobbied
for a new contract that would earn her
tribe a 10 million dollar raise and
somewhere in that difference the
e-network found their limit the company
decided that the kardashian value was no
longer worth the price tag and canceled
the show in 2021 both the network and
the family announced the show's
termination with gracious emotional
statements but under all the glitz and
glam the truth was clear it all ended
thanks to greedy chris another pillar of
the reality tv genre the real housewives
of orange county has racked up more than
15 seasons and is the proud parent of a
number of hit spin-offs the show's
premise if it can be called that is that
it follows the lives of various wealthy
women living in orange county california
due to its loose structure its cast of
lavish ladies has changed frequently
housewives have come and gone for a
number of reasons but in the case of
former star tamara judge her exit was
due to just one reason greed to be fair
to judge she describes her termination a
bit differently saying quote i'm not
cheap that's why i got fired as juicy as
it gets judge actually said that via
instagram live to andy cohen the
executive producer of real housewives
and judge's former boss judge spent 12
years on the show working under cohen it
wasn't until she began asking for more
money the exact amount of which remains
unknown that judge's tenure finally
ended to top it off her exit was
decidedly abrupt when given the option
to film three final episodes of real
housewives to wrap up her stories and
say goodbye judge declined check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you